[Applauso]
[Musica]
Quanti di voi credono E sono disposti a
spendersi quotidianamente perché Uomini
e Donne abbiano gli stessi diritti e le
stesse opportunità per alzata di mano
Dai dai dai dai
oh che bello siamo quasi tutti
femministi
immaginiamo di stare in una stanza con
un centinaio di persone con differenti
caratteristiche socio demografiche in
Italia oggi e come vedete è molto
probabile che tutte o quasi siano
disposte a supportare la parità di
genere
ora interroghiamo il nostro gruppo sul
razzismo e la propria volontà di
combatterlo
chiediamo chi a sostegno della causa
lgbt
chiediamo chi si impegna Perché le
persone con neuro divergenze con corpi
non conformi o disabilità abbiano pari
dignità di rappresentazione Insomma
Chiediamo alle persone di impegnarsi per
la tutela dei diritti dell'opportunità
della rappresentazione di tutti quei
gruppi di persone che sono ancora
discriminati dalla nostra società e
vedremo mani alzarsi e mani scendere a
seconda di quelle che sono le cause
soggettivamente più sentite però avremo
ad oggi immaginiamo larga partecipazione
Ora però iniziamo a mettere qualche
regola per poter continuare a sostenere
le varie cause diciamo i nostri Novelli
attivisti che cosa devono pensare che
cosa devono dire e soprattutto quali
strumenti devono adoperare facciamo un
esempio nel gruppo degli anti razzisti
Diciamo che per rimanere bisogna per
forza votare a favore di un'immigrazione
senza regolamentazione
oppure non so nel gruppo dei Body
positive Diciamo che bisogna essere
assolutamente contrari che mai più un
attore con un corpo conforme possa
interpretare al cinema in televisione o
a teatro una persona disabile o una
persona grassa a Chi sostiene la
battaglia della del gruppo lgbt Diciamo
che può continuare a farlo soltanto chi
ad esempio utilizza l'asterisco Lush va
a chi crede che sia donna chiunque si
senta tale oppure Chi sostiene l'idea
della gestazione per altri
cosa succederà che i nostri insiemi
inizieranno a diventare più piccoli e le
persone inizieranno a uscire dal gruppi
di sostegno delle varie cause non perché
non credono più in qualcosa in cui
credevano cinque minuti prima ma perché
non sono disponibili a battersi e a
spendersi per qualcosa con gli strumenti
che gli sono stati imposti però
rimarranno ancora tutti i femministi e
ora quindi ritorniamo alle nostre 100
persone iniziali abbiamo detto erano
quasi più o meno tutte disposte a
battersi per la parità di genere bene
Ora gli diciamo che può continuare a
farlo soltanto chi Per esempio sostiene
le quote rosa oppure un aborto senza
limiti temporali
non soltanto gli diciamo anche che può
rimanere femminista soltanto chi si
spende per tutte le battaglie di cui
abbiamo parlato con tutti gli strumenti
le parole e le regole che gli abbiamo
imposto chi rimarrà a lottare per la
causa femminista che è quella per cui
all'inizio erano praticamente tutti
disposti a lottare le persone che vedete
all'interno di quelle
dell'intersezione di quegli insiemi
immensamente meno di prima Questo è
quello che sta facendo che stanno
facendo l'interpretazione e il
linguaggio del femminismo intersezionale
oggi perlomeno in Italia Io sono
Maurizio Triggiani scrivo mi occupo di
strategia commerciale da vent'anni e vi
posso dire che immensamente meno se si
vuole vendere qualcosa in questo caso un
cambiamento culturale non è un buon
target
il femminismo intersezionale è la
corrente femminista più forte in Italia
in questo momento nel 1989 la
professoressa di legge Kimberly Creation
ha coniato questo termine
intersezionalità per spiegare i balias e
le violenze unici che le donne nere
subivano in America l'ha utilizzato per
spiegare ad esempio a un tribunale
perché non avrebbe dovuto far cadere un
caso di discriminazione portato avanti
da donne nere nei confronti di
un'azienda soltanto perché questa
azienda aveva assunto uomini neri e
donne bianche Cioè quindi mostrato in
maniera cristallina il modo in cui
diverse caratteristiche minoritarie
collidono tra di loro creando più strati
di discriminazione quindi certo le donne
sono discriminate ma lo sono di più se
sono nere se sono disabili se sono
lesbiche se sono grasse e fino a quel
momento il femminismo aveva privilegiato
soltanto le donne foglie bianche questo
termine è poi entrato nell'uso comune e
anni dopo in un'intervista la Creation
ci ha detto che non è mai stato sua
intenzione far diventare
l'intersezionalità una grande teoria del
tutto ma ha detto se questo termine vi
aiuta a spiegare bene altrimenti non è
che dovete utilizzarlo per forza
bellissimo avere degli strumenti che ci
aiuterà a interpretare la realtà e
bellissima la teoria intersezionale non
bisogna però confondere le teorie
sociologiche con leggi matematiche
scritte nel granito Eppure soprattutto
online gli spazi di interpretazione non
vengono oggi concessi pena essere
appellati con quelli che sono i più
odiosi insulti dei nostri tempi sempre
più spesso utilizzati a sproposito
omofobo razzista Misogino abilista
benaltrista soltanto per citarne alcuni
una volta una persona mi ha detto il
femminismo è intersezionale per dirmi
che una mia idea rispetto a un tema
molto specifico che era diversa dalla
sua mi impediva di chiamarmi femminista
e qui vediamo che abbiamo un problema
perché è femminismo Non Può voler dire
zittire le donne e la loro libertà e
diversità di opinione Io mi chiamo
Beatrice Zacco nella vita mi occupo di
marketing e la mia formazione includa
include i media e gender studies e vi
posso dire che questo tipo di femminismo
sta facendo grandi danni o meglio il suo
linguaggio perché finisce per ferire
chiunque incontri sul suo cammino e
soprattutto va ad escludere dei
preziosissimi alleati soltanto perché
non si omologano al pensiero dominante
della bolla
esistono tantissimi femminismi
praticamente da quando nel 1700 si è
posta per la prima volta in Occidente la
questione femminile ne esistono tanti
per il semplice fatto che le donne non
sono una minoranza Le donne sono metà
del pianeta non è pensabile che abbiano
tutte la stessa interpretazione della
parità di genere non è pensabile che
siano tutte allo stesso punto del
proprio cammino per l'emancipazione la
critica portata oggi dal femminismo
intersezionale nei confronti del
femminismo mainstream che per intenderci
del femminismo delle suffragette dei
salotti Borghesi quello che comunque ci
ha dato il voto l'aborto il divorzio
quello che ci ha fatto abolire il
delitto d'onore quello che ci ha dato
Almeno su carta la qualità salariale è
quella di aver privilegiato le donne
bianche di classe agiata quelle
privilegiate
il fatto che sia nato e abbia sia stato
portato avanti dalle donne privilegiate
non è un fenomeno tamorzare Ma
semplicemente da capire e per farlo ci
viene in aiuto la piramide dei bisogni
dell'essere umano di maslo questa
piramide va letta dal basso verso l'alto
in cui in basso abbiamo i bisogni
fondamentali dell'uomo quelli primari
che quelli sono un tetto sopra la testa
il bisogno di sicurezza un lavoro quindi
del denaro una famiglia e così via è
soltanto quando le persone soddisfano
questi primi bisogni fondamentali che
possono alzare lo sguardo e occuparsi di
altro ed è per questo che le persone
privilegiate ci arrivano prima perché
non dovendosi più occupare appunto di
questi bisogni primari hanno il tempo e
lo spazio per dedicarsi alla propria
autorealizzazione in cui sicuramente
includiamo anche il proprio posto e la
propria condizione nella società
il meccanismo ovviamente non vale solo
per le donne vale anche per gli uomini
Quello che il femminismo avrebbe e
dovrebbe fare avrebbe dovuto e dovrebbe
fare è di tenere la porta aperta per chi
è rimasto indietro per chi intersecata
la condizione femminile ha un ulteriore
condizione di svantaggio per chi è
Povera perché è disabile per chi è nera
per chi è omosessuale per chi è
transessuale invece che cosa sta facendo
da un lato sta escludendo dal dialogo le
femministe moderate il nome del loro
effettivo privilegio ma che nei nostri
Paesi nei paesi occidentali sono la
maggior parte delle femministe e che
oggi hanno voci autorevoli e quindi
efficaci Allora è una lotta di classe
non è neanche una lotta di classe perché
il linguaggio del femminismo
intersezionale è sempre più alto sempre
più difficile da comprendere ed esclude
quasi in automatico la categoria di
donne che dovrebbe difendere soprattutto
cioè le donne più deboli il famoso non
si può più dire niente Non fa altro che
rappresentare la difficoltà delle
persone normali di accedere a una serie
di tematiche che sono ormai considerate
un tabù A meno che non si abbia voglia
di attaccare o di essere attaccati
qualche esempio non si può più parlare
serenamente di genere di sesso di
famiglia ma neanche di denaro di lavoro
di clima questi e molti altri sono tutti
argomenti ad esclusivo appannaggio di
quella famosa intersezione che è pronta
a ferire chiunque incontri sul suo
cammino
dichiarandolo suo acerrimo nemico
soltanto perché dice una parola
sbagliata oppure ha una fortuna di
troppo ed è su questo concetto che
adesso vogliamo presentarvi la prima
grande esclusa dalla conversazione
femminista odierna la signora Maria del
parchetto
la signora Maria del parchetto è fuori
dalla bolla mediatica dove il femminismo
è perfetta lotta contro ogni oppressione
non è uno stereotipo vagamente sessista
come non so la casalinga di Voghera
rappresenta semplicemente una donna
normale che non necessariamente Povera o
in difficoltà
banalmente ha il famoso carico mentale
di lavoro cura e quotidianità e non ha
tempo di partecipare attivamente con gli
strumenti sempre più esigenti alla
conversazione sulla questione femminile
insomma la signora Maria del parchetto
potrebbe essere ognuna di noi
il femminismo lotta perché la signora
Maria del parchetto non sia subordinata
al marito perché i suoi figli possano
studiare per la sua indipendenza
economica e psicologica spesso la
signora Maria del parchetto non sa
nemmeno che cosa sia la schwa a volte
non è neanche favorevole all'aborto se
le diciamo che deve declinare le
professioni al femminile oppure le
diciamo che non deve comprare fast
fashion perché non è sostenibile anche
se costa poco oppure le spieghiamo con
quali parole dovrebbe parlare quando si
rivolge magari anche a se stessa
riferendosi a un corpo disabile a un
corpo grasso oppure all'omosessualità
dei suoi figli lei strabuzzerà gli occhi
e ci dirà che i suoi problemi sono altri
che Queste sono tutte sciocchezze non è
dandole della benaltrista che la
convinceremo del contrario
passiamo ora al secondo grande escluso
dalla conversazione femminista l'uomo il
femminismo radicale vede nell'uomo il
suo grande nemico in teoria il
femminismo intersezionale non lo
percepisce come suo antagonista ma vede
come Apice del privilegio l'uomo bianco
etero cisgender e benestante
colui che esente da qualsiasi
oppressione può sguazzare nel
patriarcato come gli pare e magari gli
piace anche
l'uomo esente da oppressioni che poi
Parliamone è libero di partecipare alla
discussione femminista soltanto quando
accetti di non capire niente delle
oppressioni perché sono troppo lontane
dalla sua condizione ovvero L'uomo è un
alleato soltanto se sta zitto
chiunque sia in una relazione di coppia
con un uomo sa che gli ha dovuto
spiegare delle cose sulla condizione di
donna di Madre sul Perché certe
affermazioni osservazioni apparentemente
innocue sono in realtà svilenti e
chiunque sia in una relazione con un
uomo sa che ha potuto ottenere dei
risultati più efficaci utilizzando un
linguaggio semplice che abbracciasse il
compromesso con pazienza perché qui non
stiamo parlando di ciò che più o meno
giusto perché è ovvio che noi vorremmo
tutto Lo vorremmo subito senza bisogno
di chiederlo ma se con gli uomini
dividiamo il pianeta dividiamo i nostri
figli la famiglia e finalmente iniziamo
a dividere con loro anche i posti di
potere Allora noi dobbiamo parlare con
gli uomini in maniera efficace non
respingente Insomma lo so che a volte ci
piacerebbe ma dargli del cretino non è
un buon modo di portarli dove abbiamo
bisogno che stiano cioè al nostro fianco
no
il viaggio verso
definizione di oppressioni è stata una
presa di posizione di consapevolezza
Anzi fondamentale e rivoluzionaria che
sta però perdendo le simpatie popolari
come vediamo appunto dal nascere sempre
più veloce di derive ultraconservatrici
anche nel mondo occidentale perché di
fronte a un progressismo ostile e che le
persone non capiscono preferiscono le
persone rifugiarsi in un linguaggio
populista E rassicurante ed è per questo
che oggi siamo qui per portarvi un'idea
che ci serve un femminismo nuovo che sia
veramente inclusivo e quindi efficace
perché coinvolge più persone possibile
e che tenga conto delle intersezioni
Perché le intersezioni sono fondamentali
nella lotta femminista Ma non per
escludere Chi non lotta simultaneamente
con le stesse parole gli stessi
strumenti per ogni singola causa ma per
dare rilievo e valore ad ogni singola
narrazione Puntando il riflettore su
quello che le unisce tutte e non su
quello che le divide in attesa Forse un
giorno sarebbe bello di non dover
nemmeno più spingere da una parte sola
per riequilibrare il mondo e allora
forse il femminismo lo potremo chiamare
personismo il pensiero secondo cui ogni
essere umano nasce libero di essere se
stesso con gli stessi diritti e la
stessa libertà
una Società Democratica non può trovare
espressione in un'unica voce perché in
un mondo libero siamo anche liberi di
avere idee e opinioni diverse Io direi
meno male non si può mettere in ordine
la libertà di pensiero E allora forse
dovremmo imparare a rispettare le nostre
differenze e unirci tutti in una causa
comune alle persone per bene creare un
mondo più giusto in cui ogni persona
conta Grazie
[Musica]